hi Pam hi I'm great so Pam I'd like you
to keep a log of everything Michael does
hour-by-hour so that we can analyze it
at corporate okay thanks hey coselli the
cars Cosby Maserati oh no Jennifer - pop
- once a year they bring in a little
cart and they give away free pretzels
it's really not a big deal to some
people it is Oh
I wake up every morning in a bed that's
too small driving my daughter to a
school that's too expensive and then I
go to work to a job for which I get paid
too little but on pretzel day a lot of
my pretzel day cuz they actually got
tough in everything but they were asking
about with cupcakes The Chronicles of
Narnia
uh-huh who invented cupcakes right hey
hey hey fellas
what are you doing I'm just saying hi to
Bob no I think you're cutting in line
those little bells guy no no settle down
no way Oh get in the back please well
the pair of Mary's this is pretzel day
Michael no cuts Oh Pam just a woman I'd
like to see you read my mind
great I thought you might want to use
this time to authorize some checks I
thought that maybe you could wait in
line for me while I go to the bathroom
you're an angel
hey why don't you just go up to your
office get some work done
and I'll bring you a pretzel because I
like them a certain way and if we get
screwed up then this whole thing's blown
you know I just think it's really
important that you'd be productive today
yeah
productivity starts with patience and
determination I'll be back hi please
tell me you have a sweet pretzel left we
do and we have 18 different toppings we
have sweet glazed cinnamon sugar
chocolate white chocolate fudge M&Ms
caramel dipped mint chip chocolate chip
marshmallows nuts
toffee nuts coconut peanut butter
drizzle Oreo sprinkles cotton candy bits
in powdered sugar is there any way you
could do all the works you got it
oh right thank you
Oh mr. Kelly hey the cars going on we
have a deal
Deal or No Deal let's make a deal so
what is the deal
oh hey everyone I am officially
streamlining the efficiency of this
corporation ii ii i yes ii toby ii i am
insisting on increased accountability
from every single one of you count
Michael what's going on and I will be
taking questions did you have a lot of
sugar today Michael what's in your suit
Carlton oh one question at a time please
Phyllis Stanley I want you to switch
desk I'm going to reorganize and
restructure the physical layout of the
office to maximize everything I think
gonna lock done no you on paper at least
and we are after all a paper company
are we not are we not are we not are you
with me are you with me thank you very
much Dunder Mifflin this is Pam
oh hi Jan he's on a sales call no
message hey what time is it twenty past
five
they were panel p.m. oh good these came
for you
contract Oh Brent casselli Oh Sally did
you know this is a huge sale yes right
good night Michael good night 364 days
the next pretzel
you